but we begin with chief White House
correspondent John Roberts with breaking
news on a number of fronts tonight
getting a jump record evening to you a
tremendous amount of pushback coming
from the White House today to the
impeachment inquiry in the hill in that
letter to Nancy Pelosi we will get to
that in just a moment but first it
appears that President Trump may soon
have more information to bolster his
claims that his campaign and his
presidency have been unfairly targeted
for investigation a senior
administration official tells Fox News
exclusively that the investigation into
the genesis of the Russia probe is
expected to be released later this month
and that its findings will be detailed
the Justice Department Inspector General
Michael Horowitz has been looking into
whether there were abuses of the FISA
system to begin surveillance of Trump
campaign officials that ultimately led
to the Muller investigation sources also
say another investigation into the
Russia probe this one headed up by
veteran prosecutor John Durham has been
expanded based on what Durham is finding
he has added staff and agents and has
widened the timeline of the
investigation past election day and into
the spring of 2017 when Robert Muller
was appointed special counsel no word on
when Durham's investigation will be
completed Fox News has also learned that
Muller was not accurate when he told
Congress on July 24th that he was not
interviewing for the position of FBI
director when he met President Trump in
the Oval Office in May of 2017 my
understanding I was not applying for the
job I was asked to give my input on what
it would take to do the job multiple
administration officials tell Fox News
that when Muller met the president on
May 16 2017 he was indeed pursuing the
post left opened by the firing of James
Comey a week earlier in fact Muller was
looking at two possible jobs FBI
director and Special Counsel according
to documents obtained by Judicial Watch
in a Freedom of Information request
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
had talked with Muller about the
possibility of becoming special counsel
before he met with President Trump in an
email dated May 12 Rosen Stein wrote to
Muller quote the
and his staff do not know about our
discussions the day after Muller met
with the president Rosen Stein appointed
him as special counsel the president's
former outside attorney was outraged
that Muller interviewed for the FBI
position knowing that he could become
special counsel John Dowd telling Fox
News Muller's actions were quote the
most dishonorable conduct I have ever
witnessed on the impeachment front White
House Counsel Pat Cipollone II late
today sent a letter to House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi and the chairs of three
House committees slamming the
impeachment investigation saying
President Trump and his administration
cannot participate in your partisan and
unconstitutional inquiry in the letter
Cipollone II cites the lack of a vote in
the full house to authorize an
impeachment inquiry writing the House of
Representatives has never attempted to
launch an impeachment inquiry against
the president without a majority of the
house taking political accountability
for that decision
simple Oni also blasts Democrats for
denying President Trump the due process
of fully authorized inquiry would allow
him saying you have denied the president
the right to cross-examine witnesses to
call witnesses to receive transcripts of
testimony to have access to evidence to
have counsel present and many other
basic rights guaranteed to all Americans
suppress what the White House Counsel is
basically doing here is daring Nancy
Pelosi to hold a vote in the full house
and also daring her to escalate legal
action against the lack of cooperation
from the White House because the White
House Counsel pantsuit boloney believes
that precedent is very important here
and the other three times that a
president has faced in impeachment
proceedings Johnson Nick Nixon and
Clinton those were both pretty all three
of those were preceded by votes in the
full house so they think they're on
solid ground here okay John thank you